French president in menuhim across says
he is taking steps to strip Harvey
Weinstein of his prestigious Legion of
Honor medal this follows Weinstein's
expulsion this weekend from hollywood's
Motion Picture Academy the group that
hands out the Oscars more than 40 women
have now accused the disgraced movie
mogul of sexual misconduct this weekend
four more came forward one of them is
British soap opera star Lisette Anthony
she says Weinstein stalked and raped her
the enna golodryga spoke to other women
who says who say she was victimized
early in Weinstein's career beyond a
good morning good morning the fallout
continues that woman told us the alleged
harassment happened when she was a 24
year old intern and Weinstein was still
largely unknown in Hollywood with
accusations piling up even Weinstein's
own brother describes him as quote sick
and depraved when I got in and he closed
the door I noticed he had like a hand
towel around his waist which is all he
had on Paul OVA hoviak says a 1980
meeting in Harvey Weinstein's hotel room
left her shaken after he dropped his
towel and asked her for a massage he
said so was it the highlight of your
internship to see me naked
I said no Harvey you disgust me
Lizette anthony star of the British
drama Hollyoaks I'm the other ex-wife
Richie says Weinstein once showed up
unannounced at her front door and pushed
his way in the truth is that Harvey
Weinstein raped me in my own home
Anthony told The Sunday Times of London
police in London say they're now
investigating five allegations of sexual
assault involving three different
victims Weinstein through a spokeswoman
unequivocally denies allegations of
non-consensual sex I've never heard
someone speak about a relative this way
Hollywood Reporter editorial director
Matt Bellamy interviewed Weinstein's
brother Bob who co-founded Miramax and
the weinstein company to call him a
predator to call him a sick man it was
jarring at first and then the emotion
just kept coming I have a brother that's
indefensible and crazy Weinstein told
Melanie I want him to get the just
that he deserves Bob Weinstein says he
was shocked by the assault allegations
but he wouldn't answer questions about
what the Weinstein company's board
members actually knew if it comes out
that the board knew about this behavior
and authorized settlements that is a
deal-killer for anyone who's going to
support this company in my opinion and
that is the big question this weekend a
fifth board member reportedly a step
down leaving the weinstein company with
just three deals with lin-manuel Miranda
Disney and Amazon are at risk or have
already been put on hold
Bob Weinstein says he expects his
company to survive but get this under a
different name and he says he's been
estranged from his brother now for five
years they've only spoken about 10 times
and it's all been work related he says
he too was victimized and abused by his
brother they had some physical
altercation now it just keeps unfolding
yeah thanks bianna